match on a stick two hydrogen Big Bang
coming hafnium is going to be used in
making layers nicely because we all know
is very toxic you can see freshly cut
lithium they're nice shiny metal it's
like banging together two magnets which
have the same polarity I'm hoping to
actually do some chemistry with
brilliant which is why I've bought it
them yeah it's pretty toxic it's range
of chemistry is relatively limited but
also the other allotrope of carbon which
is diamond is extremely hard that
although the elements at this part of
the periodic table are very unstable it
took a guy called Charles James in 1911
a famous fifteen thousand times of
recrystallization you ready okay
whoa and there she blows it's meant to
be pale green but I've never actually
seen it
you have this under coating on the front
of your mirror it's rather like having a
large bubble and banging a smaller
bubble into it and suddenly you make a
really wobbly bubble so this is a piece
of poly crystalline silicon now then
that was a really really energetic
reaction it's actually a good reaction
to have two chlorine because like the
label says it's actually quite toxic so
the blue one in the middle of this of
this series is argon one of my
colleagues who used to work with it
described it as evil it quickly forms a
layer of sort of oxides and nitrides in
the egg so here we have a sample of
titanium wire and you can see it's about
0.1 millimeters in diameter and there's
20 meters of it on this kit on this reel
so again it's a very nice malleable tin
for tintype foil nickel is a metal which
can produce allergies in some people two
really nice flows just like a liquid the
forms really quite nice balls because
modern UK coins although they have
copper inside have iron inside so with a
magnet you can just pick them up let's
give this a go
whoa like bullets they're quite
incredible so this is a small sample of
germanium it is said that people get off
the bus when selenium chemists get on
and now we will pour the bromine into
the bottle so you can see the liquid
bromine at the bottom is that it's used
in smoke alarms these are some of the
neodymium atoms that are isolated in the
glass that contains yttrium and
aluminium together some years ago we had
a professor here who bought a really big
Krypton fluoride laser because it's
generated as the byproduct of one of the
testing of atomic bombs so we have to
handle this under nitrogen just
generally it will form an oxide layer
today I actually have here a vodka glass
made out of zirconium because the gases
are gaining more energy and they were
occupying more space and becoming more
buoyant so the helium is gone back to
the ceiling where it really wants to be
the niobium compound gave both results
at the same time most organisms
beginning with you and me and going down
to bacteria have enzymes that contain
molybdenum to chromium to transition
metal they have discovered that the
chemistry of technetium is in many ways
quite similar
very nice sample everything and very
useful for catalytic chemistry rhodium
is a very rare metal the price of
palladium has gone down recently though
it was used as they are still used as
the basis for photographic film and we
look through and we look at the
different colors of the lines now I'm
not going to touch the cadmium because
we know about some of the issues of
toxicity see a beautiful sample of tin
metal and you see it's a really
beautiful rod
there it goes all right so that's quite
spectacular at the end Timoney so here
we have antimony this bell-shaped here
is a sample of tellurium purple crystals
of iodine now subliming and becoming
more volatile ready we have a gram of
caesium in a glass vial we have our
remote-control device let's see what
happens when we put it into water
lanthanum is the first element in the
series called the rare earths they're
not terribly rare would you believe it's
used in self-cleaning ovens but perhaps
the most interesting one is that it's
been used to enable us to get within one
one thousandth of a degree of absolute
zero this is an old chemistry book that
I've got there is a space for element 61
promethium this is a sample of samarium
and there's a very small amount of it
here so we use it in the tubes in TV
screens to get different colors I went
to this lecture because I couldn't
imagine how anybody could make it
interesting and it was really
fascinating terbium is also used in
certain magnetic devices it's wonderful
sample you'd be talking about tens of
millions of atoms hold me it was a very
interesting element because it has the
highest magnetic moment I think this is
one of the ones which because of its
pink coloration gets used in Julian
things like sunglasses and things like
life memory serves and this was the
world's supply of proact inium so this
is your terbium and it's a very very old
research sample and you can see that the
label is handwritten so this is a very
very special sample of lutetium again
from the bottom end of the periodic
table the lanthanides so this is a
sample of tantalum wire it's very high
quality research sample point two
millimeters in diameter tantalum haven't
got a clear what is useful to record
some spectroscopic data and it improved
that they had actually made it so this
is a sample of rhenium here the osmium
itself and so that this arrangement just
seems to fall to bits before it can
properly form that the iridium sample is
a sponge it's a very very high value not
just for jewelry but also for the
production of auto catalytic converters
and you can see that the phosphorous is
oxidized in the air and it's taken some
of the paper with it to generate a nice
P for phosphorus came up with the idea
of gold obvious is also a storage of
wealth because of the fact that it's so
inert if you want to become rich there
better ways than trying to make gold my
mother asked wedding-ring red material
that is made of thallium I go straight
back down to background because the
discovery of uuh was announced
simultaneously yes Justin so this is
tungsten it's long been regarded as been
bismuth-209 long being regarded as being
the the heaviest non radioactive element
polonium was given to unfortunate
russian citizens most of our students
have difficulty even remembering that
the name as a droplet of water splitting
into two changing my tight alkaline
metal time
the people who discovered radium and the
same we're really excited about it has a
very high refractive index and very low
dispersion it may not have been any
bigger than the tip of a pin people
start going whoo not sure about that
this is the boogeyman this is uranium
turnings so from here onwards everything
has been man-made none of it naturally
occurs and nobody would have known
except at that point he was too tired to
repair the bench they're extremely
radioactive very hard to handle that
this is an example of barium sulfate
it's a very heavy mineral so obviously
it's pretty important our planes don't
fall to bits in midair so if we just
like tip some out on the floor we can
see that the nitrogen itself will come
out like a liquid you see it's like a
pouring water
I still get people in the streets
shouting hello Einstein at me when
they're suitably drunk going close no
Brady you can see all that really quite
nice molten iron where neutrons which
had only recently been discovered when
he did these experiments it's famous in
Russia because he was the person who
worked out the standard for the strength
of vodka may have seen light sticks like
this building enormous machines huge
laboratories or in the place where an
element was first discovered
he worked in Berkeley California and it
had the tap in the wall which he could
open and Largo would come out hassium I
knew nothing about her soon should we
make something up because for the first
time you could see bones inside people's
hands what you can imagine that there's
intense competition - you can see the
orange sodium flame
what's on your camera oh it is - and it
will be down here but here we can see a
really nice sample of indium it might be
that before we've started updating some
of these videos element 119 will be
announced and nobody will be more
excited than me